ladies and gentlemen please welcome our
guest of honor this evening president
Tony Tan Keng young and too kisses time
six of the gym is up with us this
evening ladies and gentle please join me
to give them a big round of applause for
their contribution to the jury aquatics
design of the year had presents mud
masks and micro ventilators the award is
an affirmation of the degree of
creativity design engineering and hard
work that was put into the development
of the advancement mass design of the
year architects office at camion road
probably the highest accolade in local
design industry humble and courage and
thank you to all my talented and
dedicated friends in office and
supportive family sign of the year Jack
people place
we are very humble and proud to receive
this award but I already thanked by
creative team and old hardwood behind it
but most of all I like to thank miss
Gwen Lee which is the owner of the deck
gallery sigh of the year guitar the
answer via face
I never thought that I'd be here and the
fact that I'm here and I'm really really
excited and I look forward to the future
design of the year fuga 1357 the first
place of people I would like to thank my
staff Jason and John who are here with
me who worked so hard on this project
and then also the institute of
architects who actually created this
platform aki fest that allow me to
create it design of the year library at
orchard we want to thank the CEO of NR
be allayed she couldn't be here today
but she had the vision and faith to
believe the answer to this light in
design thinking design of the year
national gallery singapore we all need
to thank the PDA committee for
recognizing the entire team showing that
design is a collaborative effort design
of the year Paul
I'd like to thank my wife was here with
me today without a belief in support I
wouldn't be here today and I wouldn't be
doing what I do desire to hear a lot of
lecture
we would like to thank our clients
cantique Jamie Julian is the PC limb and
Madame Catherine foo for being extremely
supportive and putting everything on the
line for this collection design of the
year rubbish fanzine series
the beauty or collaboration between the
older and younger generations is that we
combined wisdom with strength and that's
what we strongly believe in design of
the year sunray woodcraft construction
head bottoms for all the designers and
architects in this room you will know
that a successful outcome of our designs
depends lush to a certain extent to
visionary clients who have the boldness
to allow us and to try out ideas design
of the year the caterpillars Cove child
development and study center this award
it recognizes the value of design for
children which cannot be overstated they
are so susceptible to their environments
and we can help them to to shape their
creative minds by giving them good
environments design of the year the only
well this is a very happy occasion where
after years of Labor our works are
recognized by the PDA thank you very
much designer of the year dr. Colin
katsumi Oh kashimo sculptor and
landscape architect Colin KO kashimo and
associates I didn't do it alone I have
five directors here that I have to be
thankful to and of course by lovely wife
Sylvia designer of the year Franklin
Pope's we sang principal tiara design
thank you the architects in Singapore
the design industry the professionals
that have been here pushing good design
so that we can export it to the world
designer of the year CEO man co-chairman
founding director MK PL architects many
of my words will not be complete without
the dedication of my team who shares the
same passion for architecture as I do
you